alors président bush je peux vous
appeler président camerounais
surtout que c'est grâce à nous j'ai
encore président mais le dojo société
société
alors il est incertain en oui les gens
seraient percutés par hasard parce qu'un
journaliste m'a téléphoné en me disant
qu'ils t'ont qu'est ce qu'on pensait
d'un an privatisation tfhb pourquoi ça
fait un art déjà je crois et prières le
jour de passage du tfh chaîne publique
adjoint des personnes privées
frigon
on dépasse un peu l'audiovisuel oui on
parle un peu doux mais n'entend pas de
gros ont dit les tiers monde et je les
reconnais rien posséder un lien en
attendant tiers monde est fou et je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire
pendant qu'ils avaient une connotation
péjorative lui dire sur eux qu'ils
c'est plus aux problèmes extérieurs
qu'intérieurs et puis qui en plus
avaient une vision un petit peu
doctrinaire
du tiers-monde la fin du tournoi pour
moi car mon fils c'est quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse
effectivement au pays avec lesquels nous
avons une histoire je pensais pays
africains bien sûr et sur lesquels la
politique extérieure française ne serait
réduite à celle de la belgique ou les
pays-bas
je pense qu'en ce sens s'intéresser à ce
qui se passe en amérique s'intéresser à
l'évolution du monde
j'ai aidé la franche foire alors on dit
aussi vous êtes un chrétien maugeois
elle c'est à dire que j'en sais rien du
tout ce que ça veut dire
je trouve que j'étais aussi dans ma vie
tiens oui c'est baptisé prêtait
employant d'être comme vous je rends les
citoyens citoyen et c'est papa dictant
ses bonnes idées sont plutôt à gauche je
suis croyant bah oui plutôt et
appartient à aucun parti aucun je n'ai
jamais appartenu à aucun parti
j'ai tant qu'un certain nombre de
convictions de fidélité d'amitié je
crois que c'est important dans la vie
d'avoir des convictions
puis j'ai horreur du sectarisme
j'ai horreur par exemple de une france
coupée en deux j'ai horreur de
considérer comme adversaire quelqu'un
qui ne pense pas comme moi j'ai horreur
en gros depuis ce qui n'est pas la
liberté j'ai toujours défendu ses idées
là alors que tiago je veux bien parce
que j'ai été pendant étant rédacteur en
chef d'un journal ou d'un esprit tient à
témoignage chrétien mais ça remonte à
très longtemps alors
vous avez un succès de plusieurs
surnombres les deux classes et leur
bravoure ce n'est pas vous étiez
présidente et puis ça m'a été donné je
me souviens à l'époque par l'express -
on l'avait donné aussi arthur conte d'un
terroir que vous avez vous avez vous
aimé parce que vous êtes parti en 62
chez ben bella oui alors rappelez moi
mettre ses plus belles chaussures que
mes chances et minutes seul essai c'est
l'extrême droite
moi ça me ça me gêne pas du tout j'ai
besoin du maroc etc
bah oui oui et puis moi m c'est le
profane a suffi à voir si parfois ça me
gêne pas du tout au contraire je dirais
que ça fait plaisir à des tas d'amis
de l'autre côté de la méditerranée moi
ça ne me gêne pas sa main ça me fait
plutôt rire mais vous avez dit un jour
président et finalement la france serait
plus en plus métissée encore d'avoir dit
je crois ou jaunes gégé du site et
léopold sédar senghor le qui dit que
l'avenir de l'humanité c'est le
métissage culturel et les régions plus
juste moins nous vous pensez pas qu'en
algérie on aurait pu arriver à une
algérie métissé est ce que les pieds
noirs auraient pu rester et est-ce que
vous approuvez réellement la la
la situation telle qu'elle est en soit
une chose croire que l'indépendance de
l'algérie est inéluctable pas le seul à
le penser puisque général de gaulle l'a
réalisé je pense que si cette bière
n'avait pas duré si longtemps des pieds
noirs auraient pu rester car c'étaient
des enfants du pays au même titre que
les algériens de souche et je pense
qu'on aurait réussi une belle chose
le plan historique malheureusement ce
n'est pas toujours ce qu'on veut
vous le voyez wendel à l'époque non non
plus du tout depuis très longtemps
d'abord parce que je ne sais pas où il
est ensuite parce que
pas d'accord avec les orientations qu'il
a pu prendre la manche les iraniens
aujourd'hui non c'est ce que l'on vient
oui mais vous n'avez jamais eu de taxer
les banques c'est bien connu quand il
était en prison en france je vais revu
ensuite jusqu'à sa chute entre 62 et le
19 juin 1965 gelé ensuite accueilli à
paris lorsque il a été libéré qu'il est
venu quelques temps une science est
normal j'ai été son collaborateur depuis
je n'ai plus de contact depuis quand on
disait à l'époque dans certains journaux
plutôt de droite effectivement d'espagne
droite que vous étiez un un porteur de
valises du réseau jeanson seul dire quoi
les porteurs de valises du réseau
jeanson est aidée pour cissé et du côté
des faibles et des français qui est d
aider le fln et il y avait effectivement
le réseau jeanson du nom francis jeanson
le philosophe et des crs ou alors je
n'ai jamais connu pour ses chansons je
fait sa connaissance il ya quelques
temps des années après les événements
d'algérie et ensuite de
mon éthique
ne m'aurait pas permis
de réaliser cela je vous le rappeler
j'ai fait mon service militaire pendant
27 mois en algérie j'ai même lu ce que
certaines sommes pas là pour la valeur
militaire
j'ai fait
mon métier de soldat même si j'étais
opposé la guerre d'algérie mais il ne me
serait jamais venu à l'idée d'abord
saviola vidéo en france ils ont renversé
complètement faux et en coulisses ne
connaissait pas conscience mais cette
période est partie disons des légendes
et des casseroles qu'ils prennent
derrière vous parce que certains l'ont
écrit ça a été reprise suit pas permis
d'ailleurs même de donner manquer cela
parce que j'estimais que de telles
bassesses
non c'était oui j'ai fait et si on vous
propose une chaîne après le 9 mai puis
alors je vois pas pourquoi on
proposerait des chaînes après le 9 mai
d'une part d'autre part je sais pas du
tout si j'accepterais et enfin j'attends
pas ça tu voulais j'ai voulu me prouver
à moi même que je n'avais pas besoin
d'attendre des autres quoi que ce soit
j'ai monté mon affaire et que je voulais
moi même prouvé que si j'avais été
président tf1 convenable c'est pour elle
en domaine de la communication continuer
de travailler
en utilisant mes propres forces passion
vous la propose vous l'apprendrez
créateur cerrejon pas pourquoi on leur
proposerait en tout cas
ça court pas dans ma tête